[Music]
this is one choco this is my hometown
and shelter is a small fishing village
that is not of the city of Trujillo and
it's a very rich place in archaeological
sites there has been a continuous
occupation in this area for more than
3,500 years local fishermen are still
fishing in the traditional ways using
reed boats so it is really something
that has that magic sense for this time
[Music]
one of the problems we have in when
Chaco is that we are losing the
traditional knowledge if we lose these
sides you will never learn what happened
three thousand years ago I think that
when I was already seven or eight I was
very sure that I wanted to be an
archaeologist it was really a very
unique time you play with your friends
on the beach you help the fishermen you
just spend time walking around
archaeological sites we are currently
working at seven sites in the one Chaco
area and the main goal of this project
is to learn more about how these common
people filled up as a society and
transformed over the years
when you learn about Peru you always
hear about Machu Picchu or the Nazca
lines that's very important but we want
to learn not in the big temples we want
to learn what happened in the small
house you get a big picture of how
society worked and that's what we want
to do one of the problems we have this
urban expansion is really destroying
many sites and one of our goals is
actually to protect and to study the
sides before they get destroyed one of
my dreams is to have people from one
chakra becoming archaeologists and
working in the area getting them
involved giving job opportunities but at
the same time feeding their own identity
around cultural data
it opens also an opportunity for local
people to learn that protecting
archaeological sites is very important
coming back to a place like one Chaco
and working here is for me like
returning the failure
we need spaces for people to learn more
about their own past the real importance
about these small sites is that we can
link the past with the present we can
really fall you know you are not only
just a fisherman you're a person living
in that side that has more than 3,000
years of cultural continuity that makes
you very unique in this world
[Music]